we have spent the last couple of weeks
thinking about ways to well if everyone
what's that what's the title of FM 10
Bob seaman on the assessment if occasion
that i gave you just a I'm actually
earning and managing money it's about
getting money in like what all the ways
of income and then once we have all that
money whatever doing it and that's what
we get to we've only got a couple
lessons to go really after this one now
we have spent so much time to denounce
salaries wages come on think of some key
words what other kind of stuff will be
motive up so commission what else piece
work or stay with our royalties okay up
all these different ways of bringing
money in based on like the work that you
do how long you spent doing it how much
you sell etc okay that's really
important that is like that's the reason
why we start with but it leaves out this
entire category of ways of getting money
which have nothing to do with what
you're doing like the work you're doing
but it's everything to do with who you
are and the circumstances that you're in
okay so what I want to do is just
underneath this heading right let your
right wages salaries etc when they come
from is I do work right I output um I'm
contributing to the gross domestic
product I'm doing stuff right work and
that's where this income is from right
it's working come but pensions and
allowances are the name for the category
of income that don't come from anything
you do at all and in fact that's part of
why they controversial but they're not
where I can come they come like income
based on like your age where you live
and what kinds of family circumstances
from
okay so therefore i'm just going to call
them allowances really because I've call
it pensions and Lance because that's
they had an interpreter you know little
man but all a pension is is a specific
kind of allowance namely the allowance
you get if you're old enough and make
good all enough money to right it's just
a special time of allowance right so
allowances are about you and your life
circumstances okay so this is the way of
the government trying to look out for
people and Sam look you know what fair
enough do you remember we said before
Commission is great commissioners great
way to reward you as a worker if what
you do is sell stuff by there's all
kinds of people in the world and it's
society you don't just sell stuff we
still want to reward them well this is
about saying income is great for
everybody to work but there's lots of
people whose circumstances are kind of
mucked about with and therefore work is
not so straightforward like I want to
work therefore I'll just do it can
someone give me some examples like as
anyone can think of a reason why reason
why your work income might be affected
like you cannot make me work as much yes
really yes okay if it doesn't if you
have some kind of injury or a long-term
illness and you should I can't I can't
do all the kinds of work than old that's
good to a health one so give me another
one
okay fantastic if you're looking after
if you've got dependence that's the
that's the word we're looking for right
if you've got people who depend on you
you can't just walk out the door
whenever you you know very well what you
might have a two or three or four year
old and they just have to be looked
after all time right other things like
in fact here's where I'm going to ask
you to um I get onto your browser and
the thing I want you to look up is the
center link payment by now if you check
that into google since the apparent fine
in the first link want to take you to a
website and if it's the one that other
that this morning what you then get to
do is tell Centrelink which is you know
out sort of government body for many all
of these tell sent like a bit about
yourself like how old you are what your
life circus I have a look at the
different carriers do you see what they
are right like what kind of work you're
doing I you study you are you like what
your works that's what's your family
status so you see it's all of these
things right does this make sense and
you can see in fact just pick some at
random pic pick one or two and then I
think you can safely
this one
come college this year
and can perfect okay so what you'll do
you'll know you're on the right spot if
what you get is a whole bunch of like
blue square icons that you can select
and change which are muck about with who
you are what your circumstances are ok
now like I said just picks up at random
if you you need to pick one from each
row you might say like none of these and
so do maybe you want to pick all of them
you don't want to be a brief war widow
with three dependents all the different
things pick just a couple and then down
to the bottom once you selected
something every row you'll see a number
of payments that you're eligible for
right based on your life circumstances
ok I just pick some and then go to that
next page where it says the different
kinds of things that you're eligible for
he maketh me just plenty pics on the
bottom
good that way do so at the bottom sort
of darker blue rectangle come up and
we'll say you are eligible for this many
papers reborn find out now there's a
whole bunch of different ones that you
are eligible for and some of them you'll
know about some of them you won't I want
to step drop down a few of these if
that's okay and you will all see your
whole different bunch here the critical
few which I think are really important
to on put down okay so um while you got
your laptop there back in your book just
make me a little subheading which is
examples of allowances
okay now be careful not everything
that's there is actually an allowance we
classify an allowance and something
which is consistently pay to someone
based on who they are and what their
life circumstance are there a particular
age is not even people right they live
in a particular place and so we pay them
regularly okay so let me start you up I
don't know if any of you selected kara
you know what is a care of it right
about here okay here you've got someone
who generally is either very or very
confirm so they need long-term care you
don't just shove it in a home where a
hospital where it's inappropriate right
so then we call that the care is allowed
that's right or care of allowance this
really really important category right
um if this affects you the government
will pay you a certain amount every well
every fortnight every month it depends
on what kind of allowance it is okay
you'll see other ones can someone shout
out to me more that they see just been
interesting call it up come on you
should have a whole list in front of you
right be quite anyone okay looking for
what now there's a there's a few
different ones that are under the
category of looking for work one of the
main ones which you guys should know
about is causing Newstart allowance so
this often applies when either you're
like I've just gotten out a for
something like that and now I've got a
qualification but I gotta find a job
that will sort of allow me to use that
qualification or perhaps you were
retrenched is it or not retrench things
yeah that's good sir you have a job and
then like you know computers to go be a
job so your company fired you not your
fault but now you need to go look for
work right and the gullible support you
as it does that because of us to
encourage you to do that Caroline you
start I've got a few other ones here
which are really important to get down
just for you as life citizens the Low
Income Supplement is a really important
one I'm going to talk about this one in
a second just from the name what do you
think it's desks okay if you're not
making
much money like for example not enough
to like pay off bread look after your
dependents and that kind of thing the
government will help you out in this way
by the way just on the side of this you
might want to add this is not an
allowance really i don't know if anyone
knows what has relatives or they
themselves have a concession card where
you sit near concession parts of
transport right but this condition codes
for all kinds of things like a medicine
for instance and we've got the
pharmaceutical Benefits Scheme sort of
place to everyone in Australia but if
you are in a low-income bracket you get
a special card you can pretty much get
any prescription medicine for like three
four dollars right so the government's
trying to support people in this way
it's a few other ones which I jotted
down which are really important we
talked about if you're looking after
kids right or if you want to put them
somewhere and you have to pay for that
we called this the childcare rebate
doesn't cover all the costs but it
definitely makes it a lot more
affordable and it's a regular thing many
of you know system one okay youth alone
now you've learnt some major one in fact
because it's so relevant to you guys the
questions that we're going to look at
shortly most of them have to do with you
for that it's like you can imagine most
of these not that relevant for you just
yet or at least almost over but the
youth allowance is one that you guys
will be eligible for very very quickly a
couple other major ones that I wanted to
get to you um the one was a a Family Tax
Benefit that one's huge
now I can pretty much guarantee every
single one of you is receiving the
Family Tax Benefit because the more
people there are in a family this is the
government saying yeah we get it
children are expensive to people right
and so your family will receive some of
its income back from the tax that our
skin against long story and then you've
got remember I said pensions which are a
particular cut like if you get past age
65 and you're not doing too much money
after that point we call it the age
pension because it's attached to age
okay now is like I said there's a whole
bunch of other ones does any want to
call out any particulars that seem
interesting to them that they're looking
from I encourage you to go go through
and read that you'd be surprised how
many people I've never even looked at
that and like I said if it's not already
these week on relevancy very very
quickly and you want to understand them
you want to ask questions about them
when you doing alright so these are all
examples of allowances now underneath
where your list is this is a really
important bit in fact I put enough color
depends upon it most of these allowances
most allowances are subject to something
really important cord and income text
right now be kind of alluding to this
which is that the government's not just
going to give you free money right
they're going to say hey you know what
if you're earning lots of money already
well we're not going to give you extra
support you're fine right and they will
they will test out your income this is
also often hall also known as a means
test where means is just then it's just
a synonym for income
it's a old-fashioned word for how much
how much money you're making okay so
being the most Lancers are subject to an
income test like how much you're
currently earning receiving from Iowa
other kinds of allows that whole thing
then you don't just get like an amount
and it's a flat rate for everyone it
changes it might increase or decrease
depending on what you're earning okay